all right
Richard Richard uh where'd you grow up
where you from originally uh originally
from San Fernando Valley tell me about
your parents um when you were a kid well
um you know as a kid I really didn't
know my dad my dad was gone um a
considerable amount of time he worked
for motion pcture industry um he was in
key grip and uh he wasn't home a lot you
know he spent a lot of hours are spent
uh in that industry um
uh Mo both were drug addicts both were
were Co were cocaine addicts and uh we
had a there was a lot of turmoil on the
home lot of fighting a lot of fighting
dad gambled he drank and uh it was a lot
of unhappy times in my in my house so uh
were you an only child no I had a
younger sister she was two years younger
she was um the polar opposite of me um
she was she got straight a straight
eight grades you know was studied did
her homework and all that stuff and um I
did not I was I was troubled right out
of out of the gate I I was not not a not
a good kid not a good son never have
been uh until recently
um we'll get to that part of the story
okay uh but yeah I was I was I was a
trouble kid I had um uh severe learning
disabilities de de de Del I can't even
say the word de developmental thank you
uh uh yeah issues uh you know I was born
with with defects um birth defect all
correctable you know what I mean like my
eyes were my eyes were screwed up they
were cross you know they fixed that and
um yeah so I was I was troubled right
out of the gate and I was always getting
hurt I was always you know injuring
something my eyes or something you know
uh something C always going in for
stitchers or something you I mean I was
I was I was Reckless I was Reckless
right from the gate U yeah I didn't do
well in school at all what kind of kid
were you in high school uh I I didn't go
to high school you didn't no oh wow no I
did not come go to any High School
um the highest grade I completed was the
seventh grade wow what did you do after
that um I uh I ran the streets I ran the
streets I and I would bounce from friend
to friend's you know house and and just
you know stay as long as I could until
the parents said okay you I may think we
Richard should go home
now you know I wouldn't go home of
course I just go to the next friend's
house I kind of did that till I was 18
actually 17 and a half and I joined the
military you did yeah that lasted about
weeks drugs a part of your life at this
point what's that were drugs a part of
your life at this point oh yeah
absolutely absolutely yeah um I started
drinking well drinking and drugging when
I was 13 years old yeah that's when my
parents got divorced dad left the house
um mom was out always out you know doing
her thing looking for a new dad or you
know new him and uh I I basically uh ran
the house and terrorized that terrorized
my sister until until I was booted when
I was 17 and a half yeah and what kind
of work have you done in your life
uh God I've kind of done a multitude of
things um let me see uh so before I went
to the Army um I was a deck hand on a
fishing boat um in San Pedro it was
sport fishing boat I did that for a few
years um and then after that it was I
couldn't hold any kind of job for more
than two weeks I just went from I mean
everywhere I worked at Sport Mart in
West LA I worked at Super drug I I lied
on this on this light detector test they
give you a light detector test if you're
going to work in a pharmacy totally
bullshitted my way through that
um and worked in the pharmacy the card
counter down you selling lottery tickets
and it was all bad it ended badly yeah I
had a that's when I knew I had a
gambling addiction with the scratcher
tickets CU I'd sit there and be down
there looking making sure the boss and I
start scratching I said I'll just make
it up at the end of the night you know
what I mean I got this m never never it
never came out right it was all yeah um
I was a uh a liar cheat and a thief at a
from from from a young age um my father
was a notorious Thief uh he never got
caught um especially in that industry
it's it's a bad industry to get caught
stealing he never got caught but um you
know I remember at Christmas we me and
my sister would try to sleep under the
Christmas tree and we'd look at the
bottom of the furniture and this one
said Omega props and this one you know
said different prop houses you know all
my mom's antiques were from from from
this from the lot they came riding
straight off the lot and uh so I think I
learned that from my father young age do
do you feel like you learned your
behaviors from your dad or you inherited
them um maybe both maybe both but it was
definitely learned because I definitely
you know I was on some some Capers with
him you know as a you know 10 11 years
old and you were aware of their drug use
oh yeah absolutely yeah in in seventh
grade that's you know I remember I used
to walk in on weekends on a Saturday
Saturday night if my dad was came home
uh you know I'd come in I'd come out of
my room and any any flat surface at all
would have uh some sort of green glass
or brown glass you know beer it was just
beer bottles and then if I went in the
room to try to get him to turn on the TV
or something it I remember I remember
seeing mounds of cocaine piles of
cocaine huge and then big mason jars
full of of just dank green Humble County
Bud uh yeah both my my uh my uncle um uh
May rest in peace uh Dicky de is is a is
a famous uh Hollywood key grip um he's
only key grip in Hollywood to uh win a
Academy Award and he won that back in in
the 80s uh for a movie called Heaven's
Gate shot with Vil M Zigman and he uh uh
my uncle Dicky uh built the first crane
uh that a uh camera operator and
assistant could ride on on a track and
and track you know well for this for
that inst it was they were tracking
horses running running doing running
shots high speed running shots with with
horses with a with an operator and an
assistant on a crane hauling ass down a
track and uh he built that in his garage
um I think maybe like four weekends they
got they had the rough you know rough uh
in on this crane built in his garage you
know my with everybody helping my dad
and and and and a couple other people
were were in on it but they were all
loaded on cocaine you know what
I mean just high out their minds
but this thing he built was you know the
base that that that they use today
yes you worked in in the industry as
well uh years later I did uh my father
nor my uncle would would would would
just let me in like you know through
nepotism you know or you know um I I got
myself in um and uh of course I kind of
cheated you know I mean cheated it was I
manipulated a situation you know to get
myself in and uh i i i thrived i thrived
in industry for you know 25 years 25
years I I I well I somehow you know held
it together and then uh yeah that all
ended in
2013 uh when I I had worked uh three
years on the television show The
Voice and I went from the um from the
rigging crew the stage crew and the
third year that I worked on it I I a
friend of my
fathers uh stte had got the the keygrip
uh position on first unit and he pulled
me off the off stage crew and pulled me
on the first unit and about halfway
through that season
um and this was totally due to drug use
this is when I started using speed again
and um yeah uh I got caught with my hand
in the cookie
jar and uh that was it that was a rat I
got fired and uh for for what exactly uh
I stole um I stole the entire
shipment uh for the the Sony store at
the Sony lot that it was in a in a
wooden crate that was the exact size of
the back of my pickup truck and I just
so happened to have an online p on lot
pass uh that day and it was just uh I
have zero at times I have zero impulse
control when it comes to stuff like that
I'll see it and I'll just I just jump on
it without without any fear in my heart
at all without any thought or just
that's part of your gambling thing too
right I think so yeah the Imp impulse
control yeah yeah the lack of it totally
yeah um but now that I'm aware of it I'm
I'm it's it's gotten a lot better how
how how bad had your imp lack of impulse
control got you into
trouble um well I've um I've been
arrested for grand larne three times um
I did a prison term on the third one um
you know yeah discount countless my wrap
sheet is is is extensive it's extensive
and it's all property crime the whole
thing um yeah how old are you uh well
God willing and the river don't rise I
will be 55 years old in N9 days H yeah
happy birthday thank
you and so now you're I find you here on
Skid Row but but you don't you don't
reside you don't hang out here I do hang
out here I hang out here quite
frequently um I have a number of friends
that live in the you know the S the
surrounding sro's um uh like Mike who
introduced me to you uh he's there's a
lot of good people down here there's a
lot of good people that um somewhere
down the line they they were uh sorry
I'm getting a little
emotional
um some sort of trauma you know they
they experienced some sort of trauma in
their life where um their lives has been
rough yeah and you can you can blame
them as for being Hustlers and con
artists and thieves but but they what
they've gone through helped in my mind
explains how they why they're here I'm a
product of my
environment I'm I am a direct product of
my environment
yeah it's almost like we all are yeah
yeah absolutely absolutely and and there
is a I had a choice on which path I took
you know what I mean um and I've always
taken the path of of least resistance
always taking the path of least
resistance
um but uh I yeah I had
uh yeah I I have some stories you know
many times in my life I've come seconds
and inches from
Death what what were the
circumstances um well you know either
accidents car accidents uh motorcycle
accidents
um
Gunplay um uh
yeah uh I am uh I think maybe one of
three white boys from White
Fence uh from White Fence Westside like
Street gang yeah Hispanic Street gang
yeah yeah a big
one notorious notorious
yes um but that was all kind of part of
my uh I guess you could
say Spiritual Awakening I had when uh I
was 50 years
old tell me about that
um well it's
uh I was
um I was uh I was experimenting with a
drug called
DMT and uh I also had a girlfriend at
the time who I had no idea what she was
doing to me but she was um she was like
I don't know like three or four credits
away from getting her psych degree um um
and she's bad shiing an crazy she's
totally bipolar right so and then she
you know she does she smokes weed and
speed she she kind of knows how to like
when to do and for the most part you
know it stays pretty even kill she
she'll get out there sometimes but when
she does she's uh it's all good she's
fun you know I mean she just talks a lot
and laughs a lot and and it's just like
then you try to keep up with her listen
to what she saying it's like whoa okay
you start talking in Realms I'm out of
here but then that's another thing is
high on DMT uh I I discovered that I
have this very strange ability to I can
take the craziest of craziest person
like that's
screaming all kinds of crazy banana
like violent angry you know running down
the street just filthy and have the
ability to talk to them and in just a
few a few minutes I'm able to bring them
back to
Singularity
um unfortunately it doesn't last once I
leave but um yeah it's um it's kind of
it's cool you know what I mean I I don't
I still don't know what to do with it
you know what I mean um just because I'm
always caught up in my own um
sometimes these people just want someone
to talk to yeah they you know they just
want love yeah that's really it it's
what it
is everybody down here has been deprived
of that for most of their lives
yeah yeah yep and a lot of ones you see
in the tents on the streets have just um
said it they've quit yeah and they
just exist day to day moment to
moment yeah so asking them at this point
in their lives to get a job and do the
right thing and be a standup citizen
that is like when you say that to
somebody like this that that is
so like when you say even when you say
it to me and I kind of got it I got it
together a little bit you know what I
mean I'm not really on the streets um
you know I have a a spot it's it's a
really uh it's not a good situation at
all um yeah I'm thinking that's that's
another part of my story that
uh we U yeah my living situation is not
ideal um at all um and I've been just
kind of you know I'm tough I can take
anything and then i' I'm noticing that
it's I think it's taking its toll
because I'm not uh I'm not taking care
of business you know I've had like four
huge laundry hampers of clothes and and
I just will not wash the laundry I'll go
I last week I went to Macy's I had I
found this little bag was a it it was
looked like a little handbag with a
wrist strap but it unzipped into duffel
bag so I go to Macy's and I pick out a
whole new wardrobe of course gar you
know stuff and I filled the duffel bag
in the dressing room and I just walked
out the store with it instead of doing
the
lottery and it was well over $1,000
worth stuff they would I would have gone
in jail for that you know I mean
anything over 900 it's crazy our da the
da is not will not prosecute any any
theft the value under
$975 they won't even sight you nothing
what do you think of that law I think
it's um I think it's
a I think it's pretty crazy I think it's
like uh yeah it that's crazy but but in
a way I can see how you know our prisons
are overcrowded we need it for violent
criminals and all that stuff but uh it's
definitely made for uh for riseing Crime
I think in in sh I know the crime
situation like downtown or or other
parts of town it's out of control it it
seems like it seems like we're this is
the Wild Wild West right now right now
we this is the Wild Wild West um and uh
and that's how I've been surviving you
know what I mean and San Francisco is
worse I can't imagine that
I was homeless in in San Francisco for
about 90 days and it was no fun at
all so so drug-wise what are you what
are you into nowadays um boy you know I
I probably probably a bunch of stuff
that I shouldn't be but um you know I uh
I self diagnosed my mental
condition
um and that was all part of
this what you want I I I call it a
spiritual awaking um a psychic change um
uh the program of alcoholic synonymous
refers it as a psychic change uh and I
did I did have a complete
180 on the way that I used to think
absolutely and I was also
um I uh I I took a a th like a in an
inventory
and I was I was in I I knew exactly who
I was I knew every flaw and every
positive you know part of my character
was all laid out in front of me and
uh and of course you know I was spok
with DMT so all my chakras are opened up
and uh
um I wholeheartedly
believe that
uh that I felt our Creator's
presence
absolutely from DMT DMT yes and while I
was doing the DMT I was also going
through this like I think I maybe done a
little too much speed plus I'm I'm
absolutely bipolar uh and even worse um
self self I self diagnose uh who I was
who I used to be who who I have the
potential to be you know any minute you
know what I mean if I don't let me see
let me get so I am a narcissistic
sociopath
um and the only
way that I have found to
um I guess arrest the condition or the
mindset um is through 100% rigorous
honesty and all my
fairs um even though even though I still
am uh a master
Thief um
uh I do apologize Amazon but you know
what can I say this you leave them out
in front front of especially where I
live in the Hollywood Hills and they're
right there on the curb it's like I I I
I got to see what's inside that I got to
see what's inside the package I do um
but yeah I I'm rigorous in all my fairs
um I I when confronted by police for
anything I I I tell them everything
right up front on us and um I usually
walk away usually walk away now that's
that's it's crazy yeah we're we're we're
we're we're this California in La is is
in a state of
lawlessness but
um but there's some good things that are
changed you know like with the police
like I have a rapport now somewhat of a
rapport with with the police before I
wouldn't say to him I hate him you
know what I mean I like I didn't not
trust him I've had some dirty things
done to me you know by police you know
what I mean um but then you can say well
look at all the other you got away
with so you know why you complain about
that uh yeah that's the way you feel
when once I was locked up and I took the
time I was like yeah you know you just
you got to have that kind of all right
you know what I mean you didn't get me
for that that
so but yeah I uh yeah I still like yeah
I uh I am definitely a criminal but I am
uh I am in all my fears I I am honest
I'm honest I'm honest about who I am
you're you're an honest criminal
yeah do you have children no no I think
that that's was part of one of my birth
defects you've been in love before
what's that you've been in love before
oh absolutely I'm the gangster to
love yeah I fall in love every day
usually down
here it's a rough crowd you're you're
picking from it is yeah yeah there's uh
there's a lot of beautiful people down
here but what draws you to Skid Row um
because if you're doing DMT you don't
need to come down here uh you know I
usually don't when I'm doing DMT I
usually don't come down here um that's
something you know I uh you kind of got
to do at
home I mean if you want the full
experience tell tell me about before we
get into SK again tell me about DMT well
DMT uh um what what was it what's the
experience like of doing
it uh well it there's you can have
different experiences with it and it all
depends on your
dosing
um so I guess you could say that I micro
do it now um I smoke it through a vape
pen um and it's this is how it's
manufactured and sold it's comes in a
nice little child safe box and uh uh
it's in a in a oil it's like a CBD oil
so it's all the tpen and stuff from from
Cannabis with no
THC um or if there is there's very
little I don't yeah I don't think I
really get stoned off it but who knows
because I always whenever I do it I
always you go out basically I mean um
that's what you that's a desired effect
is is to
uh I basically I hit it enough to where
when I close my eyes I can still
see and that's all
through um and then if you want to go
deeper you're into it uh you can
um different words for it I I I had to
straight up say leave your
body yeah uh and
travel I don't know why I'm so emotional
today um you can definitely uh travel
the universe yeah at at speeds that are
just unbelievable like you see holes
tear in the sky and there's faces
looking at you going what the are
you doing there and you're looking at
them going who the are you and uh
yeah um what you it's something you can
purchase through dealers or yeah um yeah
um through a middleman uh I I haven't
met the guy yet U I know his name but uh
yeah it's uh I guess he's um what do
they
call starts with an S then uh shaman
Shaman okay yeah and uh he's uh I guess
gotten with the modern times and and and
uh I actually um where I where I stay uh
the person renting the guest house uh is
the person that helped him come up with
the tpine that the formula to to mix you
know that would make it smoke through a
vape pen um it's it's a much more milder
experience with the vape pen I mean you
you you'd have to hit that thing quite a
few times to actually go out and break
what I call break through um I I I
haven't done I haven't broke through I I
haven't wanted to break through you know
my breakthrough experience was cool
enough you know back you know five years
ago now um and then I had a bad
experience smoking PCP and DMT at the
same time that was that was PCP and
anything will be a bad experience yeah
uh I do believe that um that was a
near-death experience for me I woke up
face down like halfway out of my
bathroom on you know on a hardwood floor
in a polo drool I don't know how long I
was out I was there but that that's I
definitely think I I uh I pass for just
you know or started to pass away it was
it was very bizarre yeah it was very
bizarre experience all I could hear was
the beeping like you do if you're in the
hospital you know that that IV machine
it's like the
constant that's the only thing I could
hear and then all I I was in outer space
and all of a sudden it started getting
broken down like these click clack tiles
in front of me in like kind of a spheric
half you know spheric shape and it just
started falling click click click click
click not like not like the numbers of
Matrix but just like these tiles it was
distorting it was distorting you know
time and space as these things fell and
then I started to realize what these
tiles were and it was it was it was all
of it was all of God's knowledge it was
everything it was it was everything it
was the beginning of time it was the end
of time in where wherever I was in it
you know what I mean and how I affected
and you know my actions and my lies and
and and
What affected everything that happened
in that brief I think our lives you know
on the grand scale of everything are
just like so fat like just like a little
flicker of light you know what I mean
and then it seems like a long time to us
you know if we live 70 80 90 years old
seems
forever but I think yeah I think in the
grand scheme of things we're it's like
nothing are there other drugs you play
around with as well other than DMT um I
whenever I get hands of mushrooms
yeah so you you've kind of steered away
from the harder
drugs um that you used to do yeah oh
yeah I I was for many years especially
how I was introduced to Skid Row um
there was uh basically all the time that
I worked in the mo picture industry I
was I was a cocaine addict I smoked
cocaine and then maybe the last two
years I I was IV drug user of
cocaine you were doing crack crack yeah
yeah yeah I was a fierce crackhead I
sold
cars houses girlfriends dogs every I
mean everything went by the wayside yeah
many times over many times over how were
you able to get away from that it did
one day one day uh you know I got really
sick I was living in Pomona and uh I was
living at the crack dealer's house these
um Crips from the from the islands they
call in Pomona it's called the islands
and uh
I was living there and I was smoking a
lot of bad bad a lot of bad cocaine and
uh my kidneys shut down completely shut
down and uh I got real sick and
uh I guess I had the shik what they call
the shik shidel effect so after that
being that sick from from that and I
knew it was from the cocaine you know
mean because the minute I stopped I
started to recover from it um I never I
never I've never touched it
since never touched it since and that's
it's
been well that was probably
yeah well I was I was in my
40s have you tried all all the hard
drugs street drugs I've I've done
everything except for I've never uh done
fentanyl never done
fentanyl tried to be tried to be a
heroin addict I had a girlfriend who was
a heroin addict so I I think I did hero
for like a month straight and all I
would do is I would i' chew a little bit
and then I would feel so sick and
nauseous I would just lay in bed and I I
remember that we watched the entire
series of the weeds you know from on DVD
we back that's all we do is slam heroin
go to
Blockbuster and be
sick she had more fun on it that yeah
she was she's still in this day as a
heroin addict she's in Kansas City right
now but yeah it was like yeah 30 days
was enough for me so if DMT and
mushrooms are your thing now what what
what are you doing down here um cuz you
can't buy those down here no no no no um
uh you see well last night I was down
here um
uh getting laid y good for you yeah yeah
and then I ran into Mike and Mike said
be here in the morning he goes he goes I
don't know because he he's told me about
you know um being interviewed uh quite a
few times and then I'm always you know
usually after hanging out here for I'm
so loaded you I I walk I go home I I
stumble up uh Central to Fifth Street
and I catch the 16 that takes me all the
way to to uh uh Santa Monica San vente
and then I walk up I walk that hill so I
live at the top of the drive 65 oops I
shouldn't give my address but hey hey
come on by um uh near almost the top of
and it's a pretty steep walk and uh I
walk up sometimes one twice a day yeah
uh like I said God willing the river
don't rise I'll be 55 in 9 days days and
I'm in the best shape of My Life
um uh yeah I am physically
fit I was uh I don't know why I was in
the emergency room I was in the
emergency room a couple months ago uh oh
I had a broken
rib and uh from fighting in Hollywood
and
uh so when I got an x-ray and the X-ray
tick goes holy he goes he goes he
has a huge lungs he came back he had to
put a second film in and adjust it so
just to get my lungs in I had to use two
two X-Rays um and he we said when I to
took that breath in and I had to hold it
you know deep as I could and hold it he
goes wow he he said you got to come see
this and when I take a full breath of
air my lungs push everything they they
take they take up my entire chest
cavity so I I don't I I said what should
I do that I should I be a marathon
runner he goes no I think you're a
little old for that you know think you
might you know wear out your body doing
that said maybe you should play an
instrument you have an interesting life
do do you think
this um Affinity to
like but I don't even know what to call
it but you know gambling fighting
drugs prison things like that is is just
something in your your you know maybe
it's bipolar maybe it's something else
you think it it comes from
that is it fixable is basically what I'm
getting at um I believe so I mean I I
believe so CU I've um well it's been um
I think it's been six years six years
since I've
uh been been been incarcerated actually
maybe at the beginning of Co there was
like I did 5 days um it was a a DA the
case was a DA reject
um I
uh it was uh you know I got that the Ed
Money um it was at the tail end of that
and I had lost my card or something
happened and then I lost my ID and I I
couldn't get to my money and it was like
it was only a few thousand dollars but I
I see I snaap and at the same time
somebody stole my phone uh some drunk
guy sitting in front of the West West
Hollywood sheriff
station uh who I ended up going to the
psych I I went to psych emergency that
night uh yeah I lost my yeah I lost my
mind when I the I lost the phone and
then I really had no access to that
money I snapped I uh I kicked I kicked
and broke a bulletproof glass at
BFA um and then left my ID and said I'll
pay for it just let me know they never
called let me know but uh the Los
Angeles Police Department
did you think you come in
for want to ask you a few questions
yeah after those few questions you stand
up and turn around put your put your
hands behind your back and then and then
the detect there was there were two
female detectives they were really nice
she goes she so don't Tri she's like you
were honest with us you were completely
honest with us we feel and we're going
to put that in the report and uh she
goes just help us get some money and
just you know we got we got people that
need some see need some work she goes
you'll be out of jail Monday you know
what I mean I was like okay so it was
like Thursday Friday Saturday Sunday
that was how Monday was it being honest
serves you well um it has it has
absolutely it has despite your less than
perfect Behavior yes yeah Richard what
would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your
life to always be honest especially when
it comes to
matters of the
heart it's a great
one all right Richard thank you so much
for sharing your story you bet wish you
lot of luck thank you thanks
man